uh adam is not here he was supposed to
be here with danielle the reason why
he's not here there's the i think it's
the biggest cat convention going on in
dallas right now and he's one of the uh
he's one of the keynotes yeah
yeah
sponsored you know sauce talks cats in
dallas catnip he's a big investor
massive
extremely supportive so adam enjoyed the
cap convention in dallas very
efficacious save that cat litter so
here's a guy who said he'd never return
to dallas we can't get him to stay here
been back one more thing he's been back
there more than you have it's the
he feels more connection
with the uh the health care workers of
dallas
no he only travels to uh red states
that's that's all he does
that's classic uh classic anyways daniel
we miss you how are you doing i'm great
how are you but i'm thinking to myself
what if what if he meets the right woman
and she's like based in l.a what's gonna
happen that would be like existential
would he move to la to get married and
settle down i don't know if you would
would he'd be too cheap to fly out there
all the time wouldn't he have to meet
her in the middle of the game
relationship right
zoom relationship is what it would be
yeah he would definitely virtual reality
would probably play a role too but you
know the one thing i honestly have a
hard time understanding is when you're
only doing lyft and uber how do you go
on dates
that's i don't understand that part like
what do you tell her i'll pick you up in
an uber
and this is a good looking guy that
doesn't struggle with women so how do
you you can add a stop
sure is that what it is
you got a schedule actually no or no do
you actually do you have friends that go
data i'm the queen no but you could do
that once you get in you could have them
go anywhere you want you just alter the
route so you tell the girl
hey mary i'm going to pick you up in my
lift i'm probably going to get an x i'll
pick you up at such and such stop and it
will go to dinner is that how it works
i'm sure you can yeah if you're showing
up on a hyundai it's just not starting
well here's another problem you would
probably show up in a honda or you just
ordered
order
for her right and it shows up and then
you meet at the restaurant so he'll
order a lift for himself and an uber for
her
meet you then he'll make sure that they
coordinate and get to the place well
listen hertz the hundred thousand ubers
that the hundred thousand teslas that
they ordered they're gonna team up 50
000 of them with uber yeah did you see
that yesterday
maybe that's like going to be adam's
plate i'm going to pick you up on a
tesla so it's like a
high-end
uber or lyft it kind of goes with this
metro image i i see it plus you can
always say my driver will be there
at 11 30. 20 years ago that was a big
line i couldn't tell you what his name
is
yeah
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]